hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from the
Champions Chester finals semi-final
match it is wesle versus nrec abdat and
if you've been following uh what's been
happening in the first match of the
semi-finals Norbeck won that one and now
Wesley needs to win the second
semi-final match uh in order to uh push
it into tie breaks and to qualify for
the finals of the Champions Chester
finals uh so let's check it out this is
the most requested game you guys
requested yesterday I've received
numerous um requests about this one so
let's see why this one is so special uh
and Wesley basically only needs a draw
in this game uh to uh to to push it into
tie breaks as that that will mean he won
the second match since he won the first
two rapid games so let's check it out
Wesley plays Pawn to E4 and Notre backck
goes for Pawn to E5 we have Knight F3
Knight to C6 and now D4 Wesley goes for
the scotch uh we have e captures Knight
captures and now Bishop to B4 checks a
somewhat rarer line than you would
usually usually see with Knight Knight
to F6 but it um it is very interesting
Pawn to C3 Bishop to C5 and now usually
it's countered with Bishop to E3 uh and
um also if you guys like playing this
make sure not to make the mistake if if
white plays Knight captures on C6 don't
go for Queen F6 you know it seems like
you're checkmating the white king and if
not you're winning back the piece but
white can just go back with the Knight
and then you're just down a piece
because white already played C3 so make
sure this doesn't happen to you but here
Wes played Knight to F5 it's a very rare
move only a handful of games in the
database and um the question is now how
to counter this and interestingly there
are a couple of moves that have been
played here like G6 and queen to F6 but
Wesley goes for sorry but not goes for
Pawn to D6 and it is now already as of
move six that we have a completely new
game uh he's inviting Wesley to capture
on G7 and it looks like a crazy thing to
do but uh okay he he has to win this
game he has to create a he has to create
Madness on the board so Wesley goes for
it Knight captures on G7 check king f8
attacks the Knight Knight to H5 and now
Queen to H4 okay putting pressure on the
Knight but the Knight is defended and
also threatening Checkmate on F2 so the
Knight goes back Knight to G3 taking
care of Checkmate and also uh the queen
captures an E4 is no longer an option
and now Knight to F6 going after the E4
pawn bishop to E2 Wesley will gladly
give up D E4 Pawn in order to to trade
down in Castle uh but now Knight to E5
uh we have Pawn to F3 uh you can't
really Castle here if you Castle here
then the Knight just comes to G4
threatens Checkmate and there's no good
way if you capture just the other Knight
takes um takes its place and of course
if H3 then just Knight captures an F2
removes the defender of the G3 Knight
Rook captures Queen captures and white
just falls apart here so instead Pawn to
F3 by Wesley and now Rook to G8 with the
threat of Rook captures Knight as The
Rook here would hang and now you can no
longer Capt since the bishop controls
this diagonal so what does Wesley do the
only thing he can he has to seek refuge
on the queen side and he plays King to
D2 and now if you look at this position
the knights the bishop the queen on H4
The Rook on G8 and the white King on D2
Wesley completely undeveloped uh if you
played something like this before uh you
know the era of engines now that we have
engines you know that you can play
pretty much anything but if you played
this like 50 years ago they would
probably banish you from your village so
King to D2 uh we have B Bishop to E6 and
now even King to C2 Wesley says the king
will be safe here so Rook to d8 nicely
aligning The Rook with the White Queen
and pawn to B4 chasing away the bishop
Bishop to B6 and Bishop to B2 we have
Pawn to D5 this bishop to B2 is a slight
slightly imprecise move order by Wesley
he has to play the Knight to D2 and then
after D5 he has to play Knight to B3 and
then the position holds you you cannot
open up the center as The Rook here with
hang with Wesley's move order Bishop to
be 2 now D5 is just an incredibly strong
move because now you cannot play Knight
to D2 since just e captures and you are
free to open up this um dangerous defile
so Wesley has to develop via the A3
square and now Notre Beck continues the
onslaught against the white king with
Pawn to C5 okay Bishop captures and C5
but now D captures on e4 attacking
Wesley's queen and the question is what
to do here do you move the queen or do
you try something else well H let's try
moving the queen if you play Queen to E1
let's say Okay perfectly fine move uh e
captures on F3 what do you play okay
Bishop captures now now you run into
Queen A4 check what do you do with the
King doesn't matter if King to B1 or
King to C1 uh if you go King to C1 then
the bishop just enters the game once
Knight captures an F3 check and Bishop
to F4 lands it's going to be deadly or
if you go King to B1 doesn't really help
you because there's again Knight
captures on F3 with an attack on the
queen let's say G captures and now you
remove the defender of the F5 Square
just Rook captures h captur Bishop to F5
check and that's it King to C1 and now
Bishop captures there's no move you can
make here the bishop captures on A3 will
just win material if you move the Knight
then Queen to C2 will be Checkmate uh G4
some Queen to F4 check will will also be
Checkmate uh so there's no move that
white can make here so that's why after
d captures on e4 Wesley said yeah all
right I'm going to have to give up the
queen he played Queen captures on d8 uh
uh sorry uh after d captures on e4 C
captures on B6 first was played uh and
now uh Rook captures on D1 we have a
captures on D1 and now e captures on F3
and here Notre sort of uh messes up his
move order it's crucial to eliminate the
B6 Pawn this is the way you have to play
it but he played e captures on F3 first
and now look at this Rook to D4 this is
the move that he missed now the queen
will not have the A4 check probably he
was banking on if Pawn captures an A7
Queen to A4 check and you just win back
the pawn but now with Rook to D4 Wesley
it really is back in the game and now
after Queen G5 he just plays B captures
an A7 and prepares to bring another
queen into the game so Queen G6 check
and now King to C1 objectively is best
but um of course Wesley just wants his
Queen into the game as soon as possible
Knight captures on D3 and now A8 Queen
this comes with check of course King to
G7 and now Queen to A5 so Wesley has his
Queen but now all sorts of nasty
discoveries are possible and Notre goes
for the nastiest one and that is kn to
F2 with check King to C1 and now Knight
captures on H1 we have G captures on F3
you don't want to allow another pass
Pawn into the game so G captures and now
Knight captures on G3 H captures we have
Queen captures and now uh Pawn to C4
interestingly here after all of this
madness everything got traded down
Wesley even sacrificed the queen and
then got another one the material is
completely equal both
players the only difference is Wesley
has a dark Square Bishop Notre Beck has
a light Square bishop and Here pawn to
C4 of course opening up this diagonal is
the way to go uh King to G6 stepping off
of this diagonal and now again Queen to
C3 is best just putting pressure on this
diagonal with some nasty discoveries but
he went Rook back to D1 and now uh Queen
captures an F3 while it is best of
course this is rapid game you can see
players are already very low on clock uh
Notre Beck has 2 minutes Wesley 1 minute
on the clock we have Rook to C8 now
going after that C4 pawn and now just
King to B1 again
Queen to C3 is safest here but it just
looks very weird to play King to B1 uh
Queen captures on F3 and now Rook to G1
with check we have Knight to G4 and King
to A1 uh getting off of the the light
Square diagonal as um notbe still has a
light Square Bishop uh we have Pawn to
H5 now Notre starts pushing his H Pawn
to Victory H we have Queen to e um uh
Queen to E5 as the Knight here is
spinned and Rook to G8 also you have to
be careful about Queen to G7 check so
Rook to G8 and now Knight to B5 finally
Wesley gets his Knight into the game we
have Queen F2 going after the Rook Queen
to E4 with check we have Bishop to F5
and now Queen to H1 guarding uh against
um capturing The Rook so Rook to E8
Notre now prepares a rook lift he wants
to bring the Rook to E2 and now Knight
to D6 attacking The Rook attacking the
bishop uh and Rook to E2 just going
after the bishop on B 2 and now Knight
captures on F5 with Rook captures on B2
and now uh Rook to G2 going after the
black queen and now the question is how
do you how do you solve this of course
you have Rook captures on A2 but what
happens after that he does go for it
Rook captures on A2 King B1 Rook to B2
check King to A1 Rook to A2 check King
to B1 but remember Norbeck has to win
this game in order to uh to tie the
match he he's already down two points uh
if he doesn't win then they go into the
third match so here King to B1
uh Queen captures an F5 he goes into the
end game uh with up two pawns but he
will be down the exchange King captures
an A2 and now Queen to E4 now putting
pressure on The Rook um with some ideas
that if the king moves maybe you can
attack The Rook twice uh so King to B3
here uh and now Pawn to F5 uh starting
to advance those past pawns Rook to G1
offering a queen trade and queen E3
check we have King to B4 and now Pawn to
H4 uh you do have a knight on G4 so if
you can get your Pawn all the way to H2
then you're pretty sure your position
will be winning we have Rook to E1 Queen
to D2 with check King to B5 uh sorry
King to B5 and now King to G5 uh we have
Rook to B1 uh putting the The Rook
behind the king stopping any checks and
now Queen to D7 with check King to B6
now and queen to E6 with check we have
King to B5 and queen to E4 offering a
queen trade and you can't move the queen
back from the back rank as The Rook on
B1 would hang as well so here as Wesley
you can see he's already down to 7
seconds on the clock Notre Beck is down
to 6 seconds on the clock so this is not
anyone's game Queen captures F captures
was played H and now King to B6 we have
Knight to E5 H and now King to C5
defending the pawn C5 was um better C5
is objectively still a draw but King to
C5 was played by Wesley and now Pawn to
H3 with have King to D4 now King to F4
uh defending and it seems like you can
uh check away the king but even if you
deliver Rook to F1 check it doesn't
matter because Knight to F3 blocks and
also comes with check and you just
continue advancing your Pawn so here
Rook captures on B7 was played and now
Pawn to E3 again you you don't have a
check from behind as the Knight really
controls this uh sorry about that I I
think uh the mailman just arrived give
me a few
seconds
sorry about that it's it's like the
mailman always knows when I'm recording
but yeah E3 here I mean the position is
winning regardless of whether the
mailman comes or not Rook to B1 was
played uh Pawn to E2 and now Pawn to C5
we have Pawn to H2 and now King to C3
trying to get hold of this past E2 Pawn
but now King to E3 and Rook to H1 and
now well H you really have no way of
ever capturing this Pawn uh Knight to C6
and now King to C2 so now it's only a
matter of how to uh how to promote your
Pawn Knight to E7 was played King to C3
and now King to uh Knight to C6 we have
King to C2 repeating a little bit but
now Knight to D4 check King to C3 and
now nreb does it with Knight to F3 Pawn
to C6 and now Knight to G1 and he was in
this position uh on move 65 that Wesley
so resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so uh yeah really
really uh a wild one and here we resign
because there's no way uh uh stop this
even if you start advancing your Pawn
this just comes with check uh and that's
pretty much it once the king moves
you're going to put the queen on C1 and
uh just win that pawn uh so yeah very
nicely done very nice Queen Sacrifice by
Wesley and notbe could have prevented it
by just playing a captures on B6 but
this uh uh beautiful move by Wesley here
uh just got him back into the game and
it's uh it's such an easy move to miss
probably my favorite move of the game uh
here after uh this capture was played
this Rook to D4 just stopping the idea
of this check winning the pawn on A7 but
Rook to D4 first and then this then
Wesley is completely back into the game
so he bounced back but uh it's Notre
Beck who takes the win in game four the
game ended in a draw so Wesley was able
to win the second match he went into tie
breaks and after two two games that were
drawn H Wesley won the the third one and
that means that Wesley is the winner of
the semi-final match and he will face
the winner of the other semi-final match
that is Magnus Carlson versus Fabiano
corana it's the one that we are going to
check out next and then we will have the
finals uh so yeah that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it really a wild one
thank you for suggesting it and as usual
if you have time to watch the entire
match of them actually playing it it's I
mean just absolutely incredible top
level chess um you know it will not be a
wasted time uh so yeah I would like to
thank Robert Aron Sims giant toris farm
the Night Before Christmas good luck on
the law school finals KV and Benjamin
hyberger for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
day